[موسيقى]
اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى اخبار الساعه نبداها
بابرز العالم
[تصفيق]
حظروا اكبر منافس لاردوغان يحبط الطريق
امام فوزه بالانتخابات رئيس بلديه اسطنبول
شعبها عن العالم وتقرض حجبا شاملا على
العالم الافتراضي وبرامج اختراقه
ما فشلت فيه اوروبا فعلته واشنطن وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه تفرض عقوبات ماليه
قاسيه على روسيا
حرب الرقائق تشتعل واشنطن تضع اكثر من 30
شركه صينيه مصنعه للرقائق على القائمه
السوداء
[موسيقى]
اذا مصادر الدبلوماسيه قبل ان نبدا هذه
النشره الاتحاد الاوروبي يوافق على الحزمه
التاسعه من العقوبات ضد روسيا وكان امس
عاشيه القمه الاوروبيه فشل في الاتفاق لكن
يبدو ان المحادثات افضل الى التوتر ومسمى
الحزمه التاسعه على روسيا من العقوبه
نبدا معكم هذه النشره رئيسه بلديه اسطنبول
الاكرم الامام اوغلو يصنع الحدث في تركيا
ويتصدر العناوين بعد صدور حكم بالسجن في
حقه امام اوغلو تلقى حكم بالسجن لاكثر من
عامين فضلا عن الاستبعاد من الحياه
السياسيه بتهمه اهانه مسؤولين عموميين في
خطاب القاه بعد ما فاز بانتخابات بلديه
اسطنبول عام 2019
السياسيه الاف المحتاجين احتشدوا امام قصر
العدل وبلديه اسطنبول تعبير عن رفض الحكم
وتلبيه لدعوات المختلفه في الاحزاب
المعارضه هذا في الوقت الذي يتوالت فيه
ردود الفعل الغاضبه والمحتجه على الحكم
الصادر سهام الانتقاد صموده باتجاه السلطه
الحكمه لقياده اردوغان حيث اتهم ممثلها
المعارضه على راسهم امام مغلق نفسه اتهموا
القضاء باصدار قرارات متحيزه تستهدف
التصفيه السياسيه معتبرين ذلك محاوله
لخنقي اصوات النقي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وقد قال رئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام
اوغلو في كلمه له امام تجمع الاحتجاجيه
لانصار المعارضه في اسطنبول لان السلطه
الحاكمه في تركيا لا تحترم القانون ولا
الاخلاق وتسعى لخلقه اصوات النخيل
السلطه الحاكمه تحاول قتل اصوات الناخبين
وهي لا تحترم القانون ولا الاخلاق كما
حاولت السلطه في تركيا تعطيل عمل بلديه
اسطنبول بعد خساره الانتخابات واريد ان
اشير الى انه تم تغيير القاضي الذي كان
موكلا بقضيتي لانهم حسوا بانه لن يصدر
حكما كما يرغبون تركيا تقف على مفترق طرق
بين من يقبل بالسياده الوطنيه دون قيد او
شرط وبين من لديهم حساسيه من السياده
الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
من اسطنبول مراسل العربيه زيدان اهلا بك
ما هي اخر التطورات هل من مواقف جديده بعد
خطاب اوغلو
المحكمات
[موسيقى]
رئيس بلديه اسطنبول بالسجن لمده عامين
وسبعه اشهر وخمسه عشر يوما اضافه الى منعه
من العمل السياسي او حضر من العمل السياسي
لا شك ان هذا القرار اعاده الزخمه بشكل
كبير الى الشارع التركي المعارض لسياسات
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان وحزب
العداله والتنميه هي فرصه كانت لدى
المعارضه التركيه لتعيد حشد مؤيديها في
الشارع بعد هذا القرار كان هناك عده
خطابات من قاده سته احزاب او خمسه احزاب
سياسيه همم بالعموم من شارك في هذا او من
دعى الى هذه التظاهرات واكرم امام اوغلو
سته احزاب معارضه تغيب رئيس حزب السعاده
فقط لوعك الصحيه وناب عنه احد همم نواب
مدينه اسطنبول من الحزب جميع الخطابات
التي كانت في هذه في هذه التظاهره كانت
انتقدت اداء السلطه همم سلطه الحاكمه وحزب
العداله والتنميه ومح الحزب الحاكم
السيطره وفقا ما وصفوه على مؤسسات الدوله
وسلب القرار من مؤسسات القضاء طبعا اكرم
امام اوغلو نفسه واتهم اييه اتهم الحزب
الحاكم بانه كان يريد ان يعطل بلديه
اسطنبول لانه فشل في السيطره على هذه
البلديه رغم انتخابات الاعاده التي جرت في
يونيو 2019 لكن هذه المحاولات اخرى اكثر
لذلك جاء هذا القرار وكما ذكر همم
القاضي تم تغييره همم لانه لم يتماشى مع
رغبات الحزب الحاكم قال اكثر طبعا كان
هناك تصريحات من كمال زعيم الحزب الشعب
الجمهوري وايضا
ههه عفوا من احمد داوود اوغلو زعيم حزب
البستان الزعيم حزب المستقبل
عفوا جميعا التصريحات انتقدت بشكل عام حزب
العداله والتنميه يعني المعارضه اليوم
حاولتثمر كثيرا في القناه الذي صدر
زيدان هل المعارضه اليوم ما اتفقت على
اكرم امام اوغلوكي يكون هو المرشح الابرز
في الانتخابات القادمه خاصه انه عمليه
استئناف استئناف هذا الحكم قد تطول
المحاكمه فيها الى ما بعد الانتخابات
المقبله
السؤال المحير في الشارع عنا هذه هذا
القرار جاء غريبا لا سيما ان اكرم امام
اوغلو لم يكن ليترشح ل اييه منصب رئيس
الجمهوريه ليونافس الرئيس اردوغان حتى
الان اكثر من 90% من الترجيحات تتوجه صوت
كمالك الجدار اوغلو زعيم المعارضه بنفسه
هو من سيتقدم لي الترشح كل المعطيات وكل
الترتيبات التي يقوم بها حزب الشعب
الجمهوري تشي بان اك- بان عفوا كمال هو
المرشح لذلك جاء هذا القرار همم لدى كثير
من الشارع طبعا اننا نتحدثون عن المعارضين
ومؤيدي اكثر من امام اوغلو نتحدث في عموم
الشارع التركي ان فرص اكل امام اوغلو في
الترشح ل- اا منصب الرئاسه كانت ضعيفه
وبالتالي هذا القرار كان محيرا لدى
الكثيرين همم طبعا همم من الناحيه
القانونيه لا تزال هناك فرصه للترشح كون
عمليه الاستئناف همم والطعام بهذا القرار
قبل ان يصبح نافذه همم ست تاخذ وقت اطول
من همم همم وقت الانتخابات لكن كما ذكرت
قبل قليل المؤشرات كانت كل هذا هبه الى
كمال كريشداروغلو وهو لمح في اكثر من
مناسبه زعيم المعارضه بانه هو من سيترشح
وقال بان اكرم امام اوغلو هو رئيس بلديه
اسطنبول ويريد ان يستمر بهذا المنصب حتى
نهايه ولايته طيب شكرا جزيلا لزيدان زينكو
مراسل العربيه من اسطنبول
امام مشهد ان حشد المعارضه اليوم في
اسطنبول وامام هذا المشهد الحاشدي يتساءل
كثيرون هل ستبقى الرئاسه الاغلبيه
البرلمانيه في يد حزب العداله والتنميه في
الانتخابات المقبله ام سيتغير الوضع بعد
20 عاما على بقائهم في السلطه يرى محللون
داخل تركيا ان حظر اكبر منافس اردوغان
اكرم داوود اوغلو هو تعبير طريق او تعبير
هذا الطريق امام فوز الرئيس التركي الحالي
وتشير تحليلات الى ان الفرص قليله نوعا ما
امام المعارضه سيما وانقسامها في الاشهر
القليله الماضيه قد يمهدوا الطريقه اكثر
لبقاء حزب العداله والتنميه تتحدث هنا عن
الخلاف المتعلق بخوض الانتخابات بمرشح عن
ك- كل حزب معارض او مرشحين مشترك
من اسطنبول جواد جوك المحلل السياسي السيد
جواد يعني ما حدث اليوم هل تعتقد بانه قد
جعل اكرم امام اوغلو هو المرشح ام بيبقى
زعيم المعارضه هو المرشح الابرز المنافسات
اردوغان على رئاسه الجمهوريه
لمشاهدي قناه العربيه
انه هذا الشخص من ثلاثه اشخاص الذين كان
اسمهم يذكر في ترشحهم
للرئاسه البلد في الانتخابات القادمه وهو
كان في الرتبه الثالثه الان ما نفتهم انه
اكرامي وقد تقدم الى هذين الشخصين لان كما
اشترى له باعتبار انه عالمي الاصل هناك
قلق انه هل يصلي الشعب بشكل عام له او لا
وثانيا انه من سوريا واش رئيس بلديه انقره
ايضا لم يعلن ترشحه وهو يقول انا خادم
للمدينه انقر وغير ذلك وهذا الشخص اكرم
امام الله هو حارس
البلد همم
الشعب يريد وجه جديد ونفس شديد في السياسه
التركيه كانه تقدم خاصه بعد دعم حزب الخير
حزب الثاني من احزاب المعارضه له بصراحه
الكاترشحه
لرئاسه البلد ولهذا السبب الان تقدم امام
الجميع والكل تمسك بانه شخص ممتاز لم يسرق
ولم ياتي بفساد المال والاداري في بلديه
اسطنبول ولهذا سبب ممكن ان يكون هو مرشح
اول وتقدم الى كمال
هذه القرار همم سيد سيدي اليوم قد يستانف
وقد استانف محامي اوغلو لكن المحاكمه قد
تطول الى معرض بعد الانتخابات اي ان هذا
القرار لن يدخل حيز التنفيذ الان البعض يا
رب ان هدفه اعلامي او دعائي اكثر مما هو
قانوني وبالتالي همم هناك من يقول بان حزب
العداله والتنميه عبر نوابها في البرلمان
كانوا قد تقدموا بمشروع همم لا يمنع اي
سياسي يصدر عليه حكم من عدم خوض
الانتخابات
طبعا هو هذا القرار ليس قرار نهائي يعني
يطول سنه سنتين حتى حيز التنفيذ لكن بشكل
عام صار انقلاب سياسي بصراحه يعني هذا ليس
اول مره في تاريخ محاكم في تركيا ولم
يستغرب احد بمثل هذا القرار هناك من شتم
للمعارضه على المعارضه بشكل صريح وعلى من
قبل حزب الهاكم اي مدعي العام لم يتحرك
لحد الان
الازدواجيه واضح جدا واضح جدا
والقرار قرار مسيس لكن بشكل
ينتظر الصناديق الاقتراح راينا في
انتخابات بلديه اسطنبول عندما فازه هو في
المرحله الاولى كيف كان سلوى فوزه وجاء
الشاب عنادا للحكومه
800,000 صوت فاز بشكل قوي جدا من البدايه
بداوا بالمومانعات والمعلقات له لكن هو
خدم اسطنبول بشكل اخر وكان ناجحا النسبي
ولهذا السبب ارادوا هذا القرار قرار اييه
بصراحه يعني مستقل عن العدل بالحقوق الكل
يعرف ذلك نعم طيب سجاد ارجو ان تبقى معي
سنناقد جانبا سياسيا اخر في تركيا وهو
يتعلق بالتقارب مع نظام الاسد ارجو ان
تبقى معي
[موسيقى]
هل تصفى الاجواء بين انقره والنظام السوري
وتحيا العلاقات من جديد بعد سنوات من
العداء الامر ليس بعيدا خصوصا لمن يعتبر
ان تقلب الود في السياسه وارد جدا اشارات
واضحه ارسلها الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان تفتحوا الباب نحو اعاده ترميم
العلاقات بين تركيا ونظام الاسد
وكلمه السر في الموضوع هي روسيه
الروسيه
بين تركيا وروسيا وسوريا لتناول العلاقات
مع نظام الاسد والتي تسميت بالتوتر طويله
نقلنا عن الرئيس التركي فان المبادره لاقت
مباركه من الرئيس الروسي على اساس ان تتم
على ثلاثه مستويات بدايه باجهزه المخابرات
ثم وزراء الدفاع بعد ذلك وزراء الخارجيه
للدول الثلاث على ان تتوج بلقاء بين
الزعماء رسائل الرئيس التركي حول احياء
العلاقات مع دمشق ليست الاولى من نوعها بل
تاتي بعد شهر تقريبا من تصريحات مشابهه
للرئيس التركي دائما
اردوغان قال ان هناك امكانيه لمراجعه
العلاقات مع سوريا بعد الانتخابات التركيه
في يونيو القادم لم يستبعد الرئيس التركي
حينها امكانيه لقائه بالرئيس السوري بشار
الاسد قائلا بصريح العباره لا يوجد خلاف
ابدي في السياسه وتضغط على تطورات الاخيره
في ملف الملف التركيه السوري تلوي
اردوغاندي امكانيه تنفيذ عمليه عسكريه
بريه لمواجهه قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
وسعيه نحو التنسيق مع مصطفى والنظام
السوري للناس في اي مشروع كردي في شمالي
سوريا
خصم الامس حليف اليوم عباره قد تختصر
المشهد السياسي وربما الجغرافي المقبل على
الشمال السوري بعد ان كان الاسد صوره
الديكتاتوري الاكبر في نظر الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان بات مشروع تجاوز الخلافات
مطروحا اليوم على طاوله الحوار بواسطه
روسيه
[تصفيق]
اردوغان الذي ذهب الى حد اقتراح قمه
ثلاثيه لتسريع المسار الدبلوماسي مع دمشق
اثناء زياره الرئيس التركي لتركمانستان
ولقائه مع بوتين بدر الاول باقتراح سلسله
اجتماعات لحل عقده الخلافات بين انقره
ودمشق والتي تجاوز عمرها العقد من الزمن
اقترحت في اتصال
على مستوى اجهزه الاستخبارات اولا ثم على
مستوى وزراء الدفاع ثم وزراء الخارجيه ثم
القاده
مبادره اردوغان ترافقت بشروط اولها
الوساطه الروسيه مصرحا ان هناك
30 كم على طول الحدود المشتركه لكن وفق
تجارب المنطقه تاتي التسويات بثمن وباهض
احيانا مشروع التسويه الثلاثيه الذي
اقترحه الرئيس التركي قد يمر على جسرين
اساسيين القوه الكرديه شماليه سوريا التي
ترى ان من حقها حصد اثمان قتال داعش مع
القوات الامريكيه باداره ذاتيه تقيها ليس
فقط من الطموحات التركيه العابره للحدود
بل من عوده المحتمله لدمشق الى الحسكه
والتي قد تكون مكلفه عليها
جرون ثاني او ضحيه ثانيه الا وهي المعارضه
السوريه المقيمه في تركيا او ما تبقى منها
اذا عمر العربيه
من اسطنبول سيد جواد يعني هل نجحت روسيا
في اقناع تركيا
وصفقه ربما هي السماح لتركيا بشان هذه
العمل العمليه العسكريه في شمال سوريا
للتطبيع مع نظام الاسد وما الذي ستستفيد
تركيا
طبعا هناك لقاءات استخبارات بين تركيا
وسوريا موجوده ومستمره من جهه اخرى الضغط
على الاكراد من قبل روسيا
لتقريبهم الى حكومه دمشق بشكل اوخر
الحكومه التركيه طبعا
تنازلت يعني من اللزوم اسقاط نظام بشار
الاسد الى وحده الاراضي السوريه طبعا كذا
كان هذا تهديد للامن القومي التركي
الانفصاليين في شمال سوريا جاءوا الى
النقطه جيده ونحن نثمن هذه الجهود يعني
بصراحه تتبيع مع دوله مصر كانت جيده جدا
لكن بحاجه الى خطوات سريعه نفس القضيه
الان بالنسبه الى سوريا طبعا الرئيس
اردوغان قال بعد الانتخابات سوف
نرى ونحقق هذا ال هذه القضيه لكن قضيه
لاجئين خاصه داخل تركيا مشكله كبيره جدا
اكثر من اربع ملايين سوريين
من احد تراجع شعبيه حزب الحاكم في تركيا
ولهذا السبب بشكل او اخر لابد ان يصلون
الى نقطه ايجابيه بين الجانبين نعم يعني
هل يريد حلها هذه القضيه قضيه اللاجئين
قبل الانتخابات ام رغم انه قال بان الحديث
مع النظام في سوريا قد يكون ما بعد
الانتخابات
طبعا قضيه قضيه معقده جدا لا يمكن ان تنحل
المشكله في عده شهور
المشكله الكبيره انه على الحكومه التركيه
ان تتحرك طبعا ما جانب الروسي نعم لكن يا
ريت مع الاشقاء العربي في هذا الخصوص لان
قضيه سوريا قضيه سوريه عربيه لكن الحكومه
التركيه تريد همم يعني تتواصل مع دمشق لكن
اظن انه بعد الانتخابات لانه صارت القضيه
عناد شخصي من قبل الرئيس هنا ولا هذا
السبب همم هو صرح ايضا لما بعد الانتخابات
سوف نرى نحقق هذه القضيه شكرا اللي هي
المحلل السياسيه جواد من اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
لدينا ايضا في اخبار الساعه
يبحث عن شركاء جدد ويقول للغرب
[موسيقى]
عزلها العالم بسبب قمع شعبها فقدرت عزل
شعبها بالكامل عن العالم ايران تقرر تجديد
الخناق على المواطنين بعد فشلها في قمع
الاحتجاجات حيث اعلن وزير الداخليه في
الايراني احمد وحيدي انه سيتم حجب العالم
الافتراضي في ايران بشكل كامل كما شدد على
ان حجم العالم الافتراضي سيتم حتى لو صنع
على اعداء برامج رفع الحجم هذا هو كشف
وزير الداخليه الايرانيه عن تشكيلي لجنه
للتحقيق الاضطرابات الاخيره في البلاد
وتقديم المتهمين للقضاء وكان النظام
الايراني قد نفذ اجراءات السابقه في حجم
تليغرام ومواقع التواصل بعد اندلاع
التظاهرات الاحتجاجيه ضد غلاء المعيشه
وتدني الاجور
تداول ناشطون على تويتر مقطع فيديو يظهر
فيها المتطهر الايراني مجيد رضا رحنا ورد
قبل ان يكون النظام الايراني باعدامه شنقا
وهو يوجه رساله الى الشباب الايراني قبل
اعدامه قائلا لا تبكي كن سعيدا واستمع الى
الموسيقى لتكون سعيدا اكثر
شاب متظاهر اخر يقع ضحيه احكام الاعدام
التي تنفذها السلطات الايرانيه بحق
المحتجين وكان القضاء الايراني اصدر حكم
الاعدام لما كان دا
الدولي
البالغ من العمر 19 عاما في مدينه لندنود
في محافظه جيلان
وذلك بعد ان اعتقلته استخبارات الحرس
الثوري في اكتوبر الماضي خلال الاحتجاجات
عندما حاول انقاذ احدى المتظاهرات من يد
قوات الامن فاشتبك معه
في اطار التمديدات الدوليه ضد سياسه
النظام الايراني يستنكر المستشار الالماني
انتهاكات النظام بحق المتظاهرين قائلا
انما تفعله الحكومه الايرانيه غير مقبول
وليس له مبرر
اتخذنا موقفا في غايه الوضوح كما فعل
الاتحاد الاوروبي انما تفعله الحكومه
الايرانيه غير مقبول وليس له مبرر من يطلق
النار على شعبه الحكومه الايرانيه تفعل
ذلك ولهذا السبب سيواصل اتخاذ مواقف واضحه
[موسيقى]
عقوبه قاسيه فرضتها واشنطن ضد روسيا اليوم
في اطار زياده في عزله روسيا عن الاسواق
العالميه عقوبه اقتصاديه فرضتها وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه تشمل 18 كيانا مرتبطا
بقطاع الخدمات الماليه في روسيا بالاضافه
الى عقوبه الماليه على اكثر من اربعين
شخصيه الروسيه بينها بلادي مربوط احد اكبر
الاثرياء الروس والاشخاص المرتبطين به كما
طالت العقوبات اكبر منه روسيا وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه
وبعد ساعات على العقوبات الامريكيه فرض
الاتحاد الاوروبي حزمه تاسعه من العقوبات
ضد روسيا وكانت الدول الاتحاد فشلت عشيه
خمتها في بروكسل اليوم في الاتفاق على
الحزمه
لتجرى مشاورات مكثفه افضت قبل قليل على
التوافق على فرض العقوبات الجديده اذا
معنا من موسكو مراسله العربيه كاتيا طعمه
كاتيا اعلم ان حاليا يعني قد يكون من
المبكر رد الفعل الروسي على الحزمه
التاسعه من العقوبات لكن ماذا عن حديث
الروسي الذي يمر بوتين عن ان ريهانات
اوروبا على فشل الاقتصاد تركيا عفوا روسيا
انها خسرت وبالتالي ايضا العقوبات التي
تفرضها الخزانه الامريكيه على روسيا ما هو
رد الفعل
مرحبا بك بالعدل بالفعل اولا كانت
المتحدثه الرسميه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه اليوم ماريا زخار وقالت ان الرد
لن ينتظر وسيكون سريعا على هذه العقوبات
التي يتم تحضيرها من جانب الاتحاد
الاوروبي على حزمه العقوبات الجديده قالت
ان اي ازمه ستحصل في العالم وبالاشياء
لشارع هنا الى ازمه الغذاء هي سيكون سببها
بالدرجه الاولى كما قالتها طبعا هي
الاتحاد الاوروبي والعقوبات التي يقوم
بفردها على موسكو من جانب اخر كنا اليوم
مطوله سمعنا احاديث للرئيس الروسيه
الى الاتحاد الاوروبي واكد على ان جميع
دهانات وجميع العقوبات التي فرضت فرضت على
موسكو لم تاتي بالنتيجه التي كان يتوقعها
الاتحاد الاوروبي وان روسيا الان بدات
بالبحث عن اسوا اسواق بديله لموارد الطاقه
لاسواق اكثر واعد واعد اكثر من الاسواق
الاوروبيه التي دخلت بسهوله عن الغاز
الاوروبيه وعلى النفط الاوروبي عفوا ان
النفط الروسيه والغاز الروسيه ايضا قال ان
روسيا ستسعى الى زياده همم تصدير الغاز
بنحو همم 80 مليار متر مكعب حتى عام 2030
وهذا ما يشكل اضعاف المضاعفا من الحجم
الغاز الذي يتم تصديره الى الاتحاد همم
الاوروبي وبالتالي هو يقول ان الروبل ايضا
تمكن همم زادت حصه همم التعامل في الربع
في الاسواق الدوليه وذلك نتيجه المراسيم
التي فرضها الرئيس الروسي وهو التعامل
طبعا الغاز مقابل الربع نتيجه العقوبات
التي تم فرضها على موسكو من هي الدول التي
قد تكون ابرز الشركاء همم موسكو خلال
المرحله المقبله هل تم الحديث عن ذلك
الامر
تلميح على الاقل
بالدرجه الاولى ايضا الى الهند هذه هي
الاسواق الاوامر الشرق واسيا طبعا هي هذه
الاسواق والاضافه لذلك كنا قد شاهدنا من
فتره توقيتها بين اجانب الروسي وتركيا حول
انشاء مركز لتوزيع الغاز والتالي سيتم
تصدير الغاز الى تركيا وتوزيعه فيما بعد
الى الاتحاد
الجانب التركي الى اوروبا عدد
مراسله العربيه
[موسيقى]
روسيا وقبل فضي كل هذه العقوبات قللت من
حجم تاثيرها عليها وبدات على ما يبدو تبحث
عن شركائها اخرين فقد قال الرئيس الروسيه
بلادي مربوط ان الرهانات على انهيار
الاقتصاد الروسي جاء
العقوبات اخفقت بل تسببت بتضخم قياس الدول
الاوروبيه واضاف ان روسيا رغم العقوبات
زادت امداداتها الى دول الاتحاد الى اكثر
من الضعف خلال الاشهر التسعه الاخيره واكد
بوتين انا موسكو ستعمد الى زياده اعدادات
الغاز الطبيعي الى 70 مليار متر مكعب
[موسيقى]
من بروكسل معنا امريكا
ثريبتو الخبير فيها شؤون الاوروبيه اهلا
بك سيد هذه الحزمه التاسعه التي اقرها
الاتحاد الاوروبي بدايتك كان هنا تباين
واختلاف اليوم وقبل قليل تحديدا ما شكل
هذه الحزمه على ما ستركز
في حقيقه الامر ومن ناحيه فنيه هذه
العقوبات لا تختلف عن سابقتها
بل هي توسعه نطاقها لتشمل اشخاص جدد لماذا
سياسي
قصدي
في الاقتصاد يمكن من خلالها تمديد
تلك العقوبات مساله النفط والغاز
قد تم البث بهما سلفا هذه هي قد تكون
بمثابه
لهذه العقوبات التي قد يكون اثارها محدود
لكن سوف يتم تنفيذها طيب الرئيس الروسي
قال انه اوروبا هانت على اضعاف الاقتصاد
الروسي لكنه تحدث من ان هناك همم زياده في
الاشهر تسعه الاخيره من امدادات روسيا الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي كيف تقرا ذلك هل بالفعل
هذه العقوبات ستنجح في اضعاف الاقتصاد
الروسي وحتى العقوبات ام انها خاسره كما
يقول الرئيس الروسي
والهدف الرئيس
[موسيقى]
لكن نعلم ان روسيا تحصل على اموال من
اسواق الطاقه لكن الجزء الاكبر من
العقوبات
يتعلموا
التكنولوجيا
لديها مشاكل الجامعه
سبورت نافر الدعم الرئيسيه للجيش الروسي
ياتي من ايران
لماذا
عقوبات لا تسمحوا لروسيا بان
تكنولوجيا
من اجل تصنيع سلاح وفي هذا الخصوص الهند
والصين
بمقدورهما ان يشتريان النفط الروسي لكنهما
بيع التكنولوجيا الروسيه
اذا ما فعلوا ذلك ان يتعاملوا مع اوروبا
او امريكا شكرا جزيلا يا سيد امريكي
في الشغل الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]
اعلنا مصدر قضائي اللبنانيه ان الرصافه
الرصاصه من سبع رصاصات تم اطلاقها سياره
تقل ثمانيه عناصر من اليونيفيل اصابه
جنديا ايرلنديا في الراس وردته قتيلا كما
تسبب الهجوم الذين نفذوا المسلحون في بلده
العقديه جنوب لبنان في اصابه الافراد
الاخرين احدهم في حال خطيره
استهداف ليس الاول لكنه قاتل كان مفترضا
ان يكون مجردا مرور بروتينيه تحول الى فخ
مميت من القوات الدوليه العامله في جنوب
لبنان في المعلومات المتداوله
اتجهت عبر طريق الاعتيادي في منطقه
عملياتها في جنوب لبنان
تعرضت الى حادث في بلده العاقبيه في ساعه
متاخره من ليل الاربعاء
كانت في طريقها الى مطار بيروت وعلامتها
جنديان للمفارقه كان عائدين الى ايرلندا
عاقبه لقيهما نبا وفاه افراد من اسرتهما
وهنا وقع الحادث والعمليه بانتظار
التحقيقات
احاطت بالاليه حشود وصفها وزير الدفاع
الايرلندي بالمعاديه وبداوا باطلاق النار
على جنود اليونيفيل ما تسبب بمقتل الجندي
ايلاندي واصابه ثلاثه رغم التفاصيل
القليله والمتضاربه وفقا اليونفيل فان
مصدرا قضائيا لبنانيا اشار الى معلومات
مهمه قد تخدم التحقيقا الذي تجريه
اليونيفيل مع الجيش اللبناني المصدر اكد
ان الاليه تتعرضت لسبع رصاصات اطلقت
باتجاه القوه التي تستقلها لكن النقطه
التي يجب التوقف عندها ان الجندي اصيب
برصاصه في الراس اي اشبه بعمليه تصفيه
المباشر
مفارقه اخرى حملتها الحادثه التي وقعت في
منطقه نفوذ حزب الله ان مسرح الجريمه يبعد
نحو خمسه كيلومترات عن العاقبيه موقع
اغتيال احد اشرس المعارضه الحزب لقمان
سليم في فبراير من العام 2021
عامل اضافي يعزز فرضيه تطورت حزب الله او
عناصر تابعه له وزير الخارجيه الايرلندي
قال ان ذلك لم يكن متوقعا نعم هناك بعض
التوتر على الارض بين قوه حزب الله
واليونيفيل في الاشهر الاخيره
عن الحادثه وعادتها الى سكان المحليين
وصفه اياها بالحادث غير المقصود وان
الحسبه غير ضالع فيه لكن الشقوق قائمه
والاسئله كذلك في منطقه لا يتحرك او يتحرك
فيها شيء دون علم حزب الله او بايعازه
[موسيقى]
لدينا ايضا في اخبار الساعه
في بريطانيا تنقل معطل والبريد الان قطاع
الصحه الاضرابات تتسع وتنذر بالاسوا
[موسيقى]
ق حياكم الله
التمريض في انجلترا ويلز وايرلندا
الشماليه اضرابا عن العمل وهو الاكبر من
نوعه في تاريخ الخدمات الصحيه البريطانيه
ولا جاء عمال قطاع التمريض الى الاضراب
بعدما فشلت محادثات رفع الاجور مع الحكومه
البريطانيه لينضموا للاضرابات العماليه
الواسعه في البلاد ويطالب عمال القطاع
بزياده الرواتب بنسبه 19% وهو ما تفضه
الحكومه
في شهر تاريخي للاضطرابات في بريطانيا
يبدا الاضراب الاكثر انذارا بالخطر
والاكثر اثاره لقلق المرضى وعائلاتهم
يضربوا عشرات الالاف من الممرضين في
انجلترا ووينز وايلاند الشماليه في احتجاج
هو الاكبر في تاريخ قطاع الصحه البريطاني
بعد رفض الحكومه مطالب الممرضين بزياده
رواتبهم بنسبه 19% وهي نسبه تعتبرها
الحكومه اعلى من قدره تحملها
وصفها الممرضون بالمهينه بحقهم اعتبار
انهم اكثر الموظفين التضررا خلال الرائحه
كورونا فيما توعد رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ريشي سوناك بفرض قوانين جديده للحد من
الاضطرابات وضمان الحد الادنى من مستويات
الخدمه
يوم ما اسوي هكذا وصف العديد الحاله التي
وصلت اليها بريطانيا التي تعاني من اوضاع
المعيشيه سيئه يشعر بها العديد من
المقيمين والعاملينا هنا
الاضراب باستخفاف ولاسيما الممرضين
الممرضين على الخط الامامي طوال الوقت
ليس كافيا وانهم بحاجه الى القيام بشيء
اكثر جوهريا
نحن مرهقون للغايه ونعاني من نقص في عدد
الموظفين منذ سنوات عديده وبشكل عام منذ
كبد
على اوضاع عملهم فنحو 50,000 وظيفه شاغره
يعاني من نقصها قطاع التمريض ما يعني تكدس
اعداد المرضى على لوائح الانتظار الذين
وصلت اعدادهم الى سبعه ملايين ومن المتوقع
ان تطول اللائحه من لندن عروب عبد الحق
العربيه
[موسيقى]
مع تحرك الرئيس جو بايدن ورئيس سابق
دونالد ترامب للحشد الدعم في اعاده السباق
نحو البيت الابيض
[موسيقى]
في نهايه النشره هذا تكفيرهم يا برنس
عناوين اخبار الساعه
[تصفيق]
حضروا اكبر منافس لاردوغان يعبد الطريق
امام فوزه بالانتخابات رئيسه بلديه
اسطنبول يحشد والمعارضه تستجيب
[تصفيق]
دوريه ان ايران تعزل شعبها عن العالم
وتفرض حجبا شاملا على العالم الافتراضي و
برامج اختراقه
[موسيقى]
ما فشلت فيه اوروبا فعلته واشنطن وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه تفرض عقوبات ماليه
قاسيه على روسيا
حرب الرقائق تشعل تشتعل واشنطن تضع اكثر
من 30 شركه صينيه مصنعه للدقائق على
القائمه السوداء
شكرا لكم على طيب المتابعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]